[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame jourdain comment vas tu
il y a quatre ont le diagnostic de la
maladie d'alzheimer a frappé huguette
est ce que vous avez vous avez la
maladie d'alzheimer oui je sais et
comment ça se passe au quotidien les
fans je ne m'occupe pas de ce qu'ils
font la maladie d'alzheimer
une maladie qui bouleverse surtout la
vie des aidants
l'un de ses quatre enfants s'occupent
d'elle comme si c'était un nourrisson
aujourd'hui avant d'aller faire un tour
il faut s'assurer qu'ils aient que maman
ce qu en sécurité c'est où elle vient
avec moi où je ne vais nulle pa une
disponibilité à 100%
et pourtant et 10 aurait pu la placer
dans un ehpad ou toute autre structure
l'apprenant charge mais il a fait un
autre choix
quand nous étions petits c'est une femme
jo elle était seule
et pourtant il faisait tourner à la
boutique qu'elle monte elle descendait
faisait déminage un travail adéquat elle
travailla à gauche pour pouvoir nous
faire devenu comme on est là au juge
pourquoi ne pas tenir le coup mais pour
tenir le coup il lui faut de l'aide
comédie beaucoup des dons pensent
pouvoir s'en sortir seul mais au fil des
années l'épuisement arrive avec son lot
de conséquences
ça peut être de la maltraitance ans on
n'est pas fort mais ça peut être aussi
un aidant qui prend des médicaments
parce que les d'épuisement en fait ça va
chez son médecin traitant et que le
médecin donne des médicaments pouvoir
dormir mais domine comment puisqu'on
peut on ne peut pas dormir puisque si on
n'a pas en malade
en attendant sur un oeil et l'autre est
ouvert donc voilà l'épuisement s'est
jusque là et a laissé son travail des
fois et même sa vie de famille et alliés
s'installer chez son parent malade
donc là on est au quotidien as 24 sur 24
en martinique il existe des associations
qui se battent pour permettre aux
proches de souffler un peu
il s'agit là d'une urgence car
aujourd'hui 50 % des aidants meurent
avant le malade dont il s'occupe